okay so now I'm going to call back on
this guy you remember this the reason
why we were interested in this fraction
is because I can pop it into I can
substitute it into this inequality so
here's the way I'm going to write this
the need a bit of space view what we are
trying to find is the greatest
coefficient so I'm gonna encourage you
to write this very small phrase all we
have to say is like why are you about to
write this inequality I'm gonna say to
find greatest coefficient just so that
my equations and inequalities and
expressions come in a context of some
kind like this is why I'm about to write
what about the right to find the
greatest coefficient what I want to know
is when do the terms keep getting bigger
and bigger and bigger right when is the
next term bigger than the one that
preceded it okay so to find the greatest
coefficient I need to solve this right
that's what I'm looking for but what's
equivalent to that is this guy and I
have just gone through all the effort of
finding out what this left hand
expression is without all of the
factorials and some of the superfluous
powers in the way so I'm going to
substitute into here the expression I
got in the previous question right so
I'm gonna say don't need this anymore
I'm gonna say this is what I'm solving
now 36 minus 3k or can you go ahead and
solve that for me won't take you many
Alliance just go ahead just be careful
your algebra your negative signs if you
end up getting any
you get there yeah you're happy with
that so you could have done it any way
you liked if you wanted you could have
added 5k to both sides rather than
subtracting 5k but you have to get K on
the left hand side so at some point your
inequality is going to switch direction
whether by multiplying by a negative or
just by by swapping both sides of the
inequality okay so you get to this point
okay now what was the point of saying
this well K has to be less than 6 and
4/5 for what well for this for this to
be true over here right so remembering
that K is an integer right 0 1 2 3 4 etc
all the way up to 12
okay I could say therefore for K equals
now what values will it work for 0 1 2
all the way up until 6 right you can't
say 7 because that doesn't satisfy this
inequality right for these values of K
my inequality is true the one I started
with right T sub K plus 1 will be
greater than T sub K so I'm gonna write
that down okay now what I can infer from
that which means you know therefore for
all the other values of K for K equals 7
and 8 and 9 all the way up until 12 this
is not true the opposite is true
right so the next term afterwards will
not be bigger than the term before it it
will be smaller okay so now I can
actually start to write this out you
know how I had my whole list before of T
0 1 2 3 etc and where they get bigger
where they stop getting bigger so I can
say term 0 is term 1 going to be bigger
than term 0
his term one going to be sorry
coefficient zero is coefficient one
going to be bigger than coefficient zero
and the answer is yes because it's one
of these right it's one of these cases
so I can say that is going to be less
than that and is it true for this well
yes it's still true for this is it still
gonna be true for this one yes in fact
it's gonna keep going all the way until
we get to here right now just notice
what we just said here right for K
equals six K equals six is the last time
that this is true now if you just put
that directly into your inequality this
is what you get right here's his term
six over here on the coefficient six on
the right hand side over on the left
what coefficient is here coefficient
seven that's six plus one right so this
is the last time when one coefficient
successive coefficient is bigger than
the previous one there it is this is the
same as this are you okay with that but
afterwards the inequality is no longer
true so T seven is as big as it gets
t 8 will be smaller and T 9 will be
smaller and so on right it will continue
okay so I have just established here
through this logic that T 7 must be the
biggest of the T's the biggest of the
coefficients right so I can say right
here I think included therefore T 7 is
the greatest coefficient okay now
there's a lot of writing here and that's
appropriate because you're trying to
prove something here they're just trying
to find a value you are trying to show
you're trying to establish you try to
demonstrate so while it feels like the
goodness I have to say this and all I
kind of think the logical machinery is
what makes your proof actually work okay
you can find this value and still not
understand why it's actually the case
and a lot of students will fall down
they'll say eyes at 6 or is it 8 which
one is it it quite confused here because
they don't understand the logic all
right but lastly once you have used the
logic you want to actually get a
conclusion from it so Part C says
write down the greatest coefficient
leave it factored so they mean when you
get numbers here don't actually expand
them out and evaluate so if you have a
look back you can see we've got term K
we know what that is but I coefficient K
I don't want coefficient K I want the
seventh one okay so all I'm gonna do is
substitute in seven so instead of 12 CK
I'm going to write more value of K am I
currently interested in seven so I'm
gonna write 12 see seven how many twos
will there be in this case have a look
it's two to the power of 12 minus 7 so
there with five of them to the power of
five and then how many threes will be
trailing on the end seven done skis okay
now this will of course make way this is
the greatest coefficient so we haven't
worried about the X's that will repeat
in the original question but later on
we're gonna have a look at what happens
when X itself also takes on numerical
values and that's when we look at not
the greatest coefficient but the
greatest okay